ESPECIALLY HERE IN THIS RIVALRY
WITH
HERE IS SIBY ON S
IT BACK TO LETANG.
LETANG FIRES, HE SCORES!
KRIS L HE
GETS IN FRONT IN THE LANE OF
THE SHOT.
IT GOES RIGHT
WIDE OPEN.
HE'S GOT A BREAK AWAY!
THE WAY HE IS PLAYING  PARISE,
HE FINDS PARISE AND GET IT OVER
THE PAD AND UNDER THE GLOVE  AS
AWAY FROM AN NYLANDER PLAY.
HEINENMARK FRIEDMAN.
PASSOVER, SCORE!
JAKE GUENTZEL!ABLE TO GET
THAT PUCK  ON A GREAT FEED FROM
CROSBY.
RUST HAS CHARIN
VEGAS.
RICKARD RAKELL WILL TIP IT
OVER TO
WITH CROSBY.
CROSBY, CROSBY.
THERE WAS NO ROOM AND HE PUT IT
CARTER. IT BUT
PAGEAU DOES.
BACK IS CHAD RUHWEDEL. LOOSE PU
IN BY ANDERS LEE.
THE ISLANDERS WILL NOT ISTAN JA
WHAT, THOSE GOALTENDERS CAN
REALLY TAKE A BEATING.
BROCK McGINN BURIES IT!
NOW.
ROLLING PUCK, McGINN TRIES TO
SETTLE IT DOWN.
GOOD TO SEE HIM BACK ON
CHARA WI'T EVEN LOOK LIKE HE
BROUGHT IT BACK FAR, DID IT?
HIS WAIST IS ABOUT 7 FEET HIGH.
HE JUST RIPPED THE SHOT.D A MIS
GUENTZEL ONE
SHOT.
PENGUINS KEPT THE PRESSURE TO